les cinémas guzzo demande la réouverture
des salles au québec idéalement à partir
de vendredi 19 juin dans un dans un peu
plus d'un mois
vincent guzzo et président des cinémas
guzzo
bonsoir monsieur guzzo bonsoir comment
ça va ça va bien vous même comment ça va
vous proposer le 19 juin pourquoi parce
que y'a la saint-gilles 24 là mais
idéalement c'est le 26 à travers le pays
que tout les provinces présentement tous
les exploitants titien allons discuter
avec les différents paliers de
provinciaux et on essaie de ligne ça
pour le 26 mai nous au québec on s'est
dit c'est quoi et à la singer il y aura
pas de feu d'artifice et repas de
l'événement dans les parcs et tu seras
peut-être qu'on pourra faire une semaine
du cinéma québécois et essayer de donner
un petit peu remonté le moral disons des
québécois qui ont été confinés il est
fait il faut se rappeler qu'au 19 juin
on va être en confinement ça va faire
trois mois je pense qu'après trop en
moellons comment ça commence à nous bien
qu'on peut aller travailler je pense
nombreux commencer un petit peu à
distraire un petit peu le saint homme et
enfant en même temps on repousse
toujours un peu un dans la grande région
de montréal je sais que vous avez
plusieurs salles dans la grande région
de montréal est ce que est ce que le 19
joueurs en même temps c'est pas un peu
trop rapide
oui pinasse à des pactes et moi je
bousille qu'un on a fermé après une ou
deux semaines déjà mais première
approche avec les gouvernements auront
parlé du 15 mai
les fins de semaine seulement parce que
c'était la fin de semaine des patriotes
donc on s'est dit c'est quoi on va faire
un lancement de réouverture de salles
dans ce contexte là mais vous savez la
beauté de donner des dates si loin que
ça et avoir cinq six sept huit semaines
pour décider
c'est qu'on peut voir l'évolution des
choses et voir qu'est-ce qui en est et
voir comment une courbe s'aplatit ou
s'aplatit - et on va décider en
conséquence dans mon cas à moi tous les
cinémas sadaoui ceci je suis affecté à
100% bon et là que vous répondre
gouvernement quand vous dites 19
si vous n'êtes pas seuls dans
l'industrie à dire cette date là que
vous gouvernement du québec parce que le
volant du québec a été assez logique et
souple dans sa manière de répondre dans
le sens que veulent s'assurer qu'on va
avoir des consignes lesquels consignes
on a remis au gouvernement mais aussi
ont fait pas de pression parce qu'on
aussi que fait de la pression dans un
tas de paniers coûte pandémie ou de
crise
ça va peut-être pas nous donner le
résultat qu'on veut oui ça va peut-être
même joué contre nous allons terre donc
l'idée pour nous je pense que ministre
des finances le dit avant moi que plus
l'on est là la fermeture pour cette
industrie
plus ça va prendre de temps à remettre
les choses dans un certain équilibre
dans notre cas nous serrer les mains
qu'on parle jamais quand vous avez une
salle de cinéma c'est qu'on oublie que
le contenu n'est pas nous pas comme un
restaurant où c'est nous qu'on fait les
pizzas puis on l'a 20 nous on ne conduit
nulle part ailleurs et vous savez nous
on regarde aux etats-unis pour deux
raisons premièrement parce qu'on voit
comment ça évolue les choses laborde
deuxièmement parce qu'il ya une grosse
partie de notre chiffre d'affaires qui
va venir des films à gros budgets les
caisses que j'appellerai les crêpes les
films américains
mais c'est sûr que s'ils sont encore
fermés ils vont pas ils vont pas sortir
ces paiements ils vont continuer à les
repousser pour l'instant
comme je vous dis on a repoussé les
films donc nous on a encore accès à des
films on a dit le designer parce que ça
venait en ligne comme je vous dis avec
la saint-jean et parce que c'était deux
semaines trois semaines avant la sortie
continue de certains films dont le plus
grand de tous et serait le premier qui
est le christ nolen qui est honnête qui
sortirait le 17 juillet donc on se
prépare alors ici que nous aussi qu'on
rate notre personnel pour leur
extinction
et là aux états unis au texas par
exemple on a commencé tranquillement
mais lily cinéma rouve lentement repart
lentement voulait pas nécessairement
repartir aussi vite que le gouverneur en
georgie aussi par exemple puis à des
diffuseurs qui ont pas beaucoup de films
a présenté les diffuseurs
et les grands producteurs halliwell tout
ça ils ont ils ont un peu de difficulté
à se dire on lance nos films maintenant
on n'est pas sûr que la clientèle est là
mais c'est pas moi je pense pas que
c'est la clientèle qui est la leur part
parce que je dois vous dire les
résultats des cinémas qui ont ouvert au
texas sont considérant qu'ils étaient à
25 % de capacité
considérant qu'ils ont joué des films
qui datait de hier deux mois
les résultats sont assez extraordinaire
l'autre camp on a presque pleine
capacité du 25 % dans certains cas c'est
quand même assez intéressant ça veut
dire que le monde veulent retourner dans
les salles le monde va leur sortie mais
pour moi ça me ramène sa 25 ou 50 % ça
vaut la peine pour une entreprise comme
vous de rouvrir la capacité comme ça non
c'est ça qu'est justement et c'est ça
que justement on doit comprendre c'est
que si nous on fait ça c'est parce que
nous on sait qu'on est en train de faire
un manque à gagner ou une perte réelle
rares pas perdre comme on dit pendant
deux trois semaines avant qu'il ya les
sorties des grands affirmé va falloir
avoir de beaux frères là avant va
falloir ouvrir au moins deux semaines
avant le 17 juillet s'il fait me reste
encore loi parce que c'est tout le
déplacer bien là on peut jouer avec la
date mais l'important c'est qu'il ya
personne qui peut même être qu'un jour
un nouveau cinéma exemple je fais un
rodage destin personnel l'aspect
personnel au travail pour moi au moins
une coupe de moi imaginez dans un
contexte où les cinémas étaient fermés
va falloir repartir les projecteurs va
falloir mais s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas
de déficience qui est arrivé qu'on a
fermé pendant deux mois trois mois donc
c'est ce que nous on veut avoir ce
serait alors aussi que ces temps là
c'est un cetain lens leader on perd de
l'argent durant ces deux semaines l'a
pas juste moi tous les cinémas vont
perdre de l'argent de l'assurance
mutuelle la mémé
or on sait pour le futur conclut
monsieur goudou est-ce que vous vos
salles sont prêtes
parce que ça demande un nouvel
aménagement les gens doivent être
éloigné je sais pas s'il ya des
plexiglas ou je ne sais trop comment
vous allez fonctionner mais ce que vaut
500 prêtres nous dans notre camp nous
qu'est-ce qui est élevé les salles ont
toutes été nettoyés et désinfectés donc
toutes les parties 1 heure au niveau des
salles de cinéma la distanciation va se
faire ça on le sent débat vide entre un
couple et un autre coupe donc pas de
problème ce sont les salles sont déjà
prêtes on a juste à eux le comment je
propose ils des romans de s'éloigner de
2 bat robin
qu'est ce qui sera la consigne du
gouvernement au niveau 2 de nos
concessions de restaurants nous on va
pas faire de plexiglas nous qu'est ce
qu'on propose aux lieux c'est de mettre
des visières à notre personnel
ça va rendre notre personnel plus en
sécurité ça va aussi donner une image
plus que lutter à note à 95 cv
l'important c'est qu'on voit dans un
cinéma qui se divertir je veux pas qu'on
crée l'ambiance qu'on est en train de
l'est l'urgence d'un hôpital
non on a quand même comment on a quand
même commandé des citations de de purell
on va les appeler comme ça pour leur
poule bien qu'on soit clair pour les
entrées au niveau du cinéma quand on
paye on va entrer en rade de passer la
guérite comme on dirait de du placier
lui va s'assurer qu'on les clients ce
dessin fait que les mains et on attend
après d'autres consignes du gouvernement
mais le jeu quand même j'interviens
souligné oui je quand même souligner que
si on va dans des épiceries ou si on va
dans des warm heart là les consignes qui
avait là où les les les canadiens l'ailé
les procédures qu'on avait la première
semaine je vous et moi j'ai été là y'a
pas d'en trouver avec des gays et
pendant grue avec des masques en train
de remplir les étagères comme on veut
dire pas de consignes spéciale donc moi
je vous dis c'est pas pour ça que je
veux faire ça
j'ai juste faut pas devenir géré ma
forme et et l'appliquer à certains
commerces et de la vie des ados parfait
on prend note de sa merci beaucoup
monsieur guzzo merci à vous ça m'a fait
plaisir